I think I'll do the usual the first
Challenger gets the game
okay first Challenger
oh I have Zen mode turned on
I mean I know who I accepted uh or do I
guess I do now the knockouts
was one of the first chatters
this was rated
Blitz
welcome to more people
apparently the world population
exceeded 8 billion yesterday
I'm not sure how that's easy to measure
but I appreciate the very small
percentage of the world population
tuning into the Stream
yeah the sign Bishop E6 perhaps oh no my
Bishop
yeah this is a good line
um
happy Sunday
foreign
I'm hoping I don't get smashed
immediately
one's clearly well prepared
so I'm hitting the bishop
this is something I've looked at before
actually considering Bishop C4 here
maybe maybe this first
this is like very deep Stafford prep
I think engine will probably say like
plus eight for whites at least
but
there's still some issues to solve like
there's Initiative for black
knock knock who's there
oh Free Pawn
I want a free Pawn
oh wow
I think my opponent was like very
prepared until until maybe Rook H2
uh thanks for the game
Ben Feingold would approve of always
play Bishop F1
but um I think King F1 was called for
plus 6.8
King F1 only move
yeah because there's no other way to
save the bishop
it's actually interesting that like if
takes
takes
black is down at night
but black is already winning why is
Batman in your queen D4 Rook G1
ah Queen H oh look at this line King D2
Queen H6
F4 and then amperson
is a nice move
yeah this was actually a good
demonstration of like the best line for
white again staffer in the bishop F3
and um
yeah there's a trick here
Rook T8 there's some compensation so I
think most people play Queen E2
and black already scores really well the
queen E2 95 like box Harvey for toys
but H3 is um
is the best move like Castle
so takes takes
I think
if white plays King off one then
I mean I'd still fight
Bishop D6 running this and if this
wow
the Block's not losing here
actually discovering this is like new
Theory
E5
hey Eric Queen F5 each one of your
streams again shout out to my mate
masiak if he's watching as well P shout
out to everyone watching neem my check
that's so crazy that this is winning or
this is like almost winning for black
and that's so sweet to discover such a a
new line